- I'm Jasmine Lawrence
and I'm a Program Manager
on the Xbox One engineering team.
One of our biggest features
is called Xbox Live.
It's an online service
that connects gamers
from all around the world,
and we rely on the internet
to make that happen.
This is no easy task and there are a lot
of things happening behind the scenes.
The internet is totally changing
how people interact and connect.
But how does it work?
How do the computers all across the world
actually communicate with each other?
Let's look at web browsing.
First, you open a web browser.
It's the app you use to
access the web pages.
Next, you type in the web address, or URL,
which stands for Uniform Resource Locator,
of a website you want to
visit like Tumblr.com.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Hi, I'm David Karp,
the founder of Tumblr,
and we're here today to talk about
how those web browsers we use every day
actually work.
So you've probably wondered what
actually happens when you type an address
into your web browser and then hit enter,
and it really is about as
crazy as you can imagine.
So in that moment,
your computer starts
talking to another computer
called a server
that's usually thousands of miles away,
and in milliseconds your computer
asks that server for a website,
and that server starts to talk back
to your computer in a
language called HTTP.
HTTP stands for Hypertext
Transfer Protocol.
You can kind of think of it
as the language that one computer uses
to ask another computer for a document.
It's actually really
pretty straightforward.
If you were to intercept
the conversation between your computer
and a web server on the internet,
it's mainly made up of something
called "GET" requests.
And those are really very
simply the word "GET"
and then the name of the document
that you're requesting.
So if you're trying to log into Tumblr
and load our login page,
all you're doing is sending a GET request
to Tumblr's server
that says "GET /login"
and that tells Tumblr's server that
you want all of the HTML code
for the Tumblr login page.
HTML stands for HyperText Markup Language
and you can think of that
as the language you use
to tell a web browser
how to make a page look.
So if you think about
something like Wikipedia,
which is really just
a big simple document,
and HTML is the language that you use
to make that title big and bold,
to make the font the right font,
to link certain text
to certain other pages,
to make some text bold,
to make some text italic,
to put an image in the middle of the page,
to align the image to the right,
to align the image to the left.
- The text of a web page is included
directly in the HTML,
but other parts, images or videos,
are separate files with their own URLs
that need to be requested.
The browser sends separate HTTP requests
for each of these and
displays them as they arrive.
If a web page has a lot
of different images,
each of them causes a
separate HTTP request
and the page loads slower.
Now sometimes when you browse the web,
you're not just requesting pages
with GET requests.
Sometimes you send information,
like when you fill out a
form or type a search query.
Your browser sends this information
in plain text to the web server
using an HTTP post request.
- So let's say you log in to Tumblr.
The first thing you do
is make a "POST" request
That is, a "POST" to Tumblr's login page
that has some data attached to it.
It has your email address,
it has your password.
That goes to Tumblr's server.
Tumblr's server figures out
that, okay, you're David.
It sends a web page back to your browser
that says, "Success! Logged in as David."
But along with that web page,
it also attaches a little
bit of invisible cookie data
that your browser sees and knows to save,
and that's really important because
it's really the only way that a website
can remember who you are.
All that cookie data really is
is an ID card for Tumblr.
It's a number that
identifies you as David.
Your web browser holds onto that number,
and then the next time you refresh Tumblr,
the next time you go to Tumblr.com,
your web browser knows to automatically
attach that ID number with the request
that it sends over to Tumblr's server,
so now Tumblr's server sees the request
coming from your browser,
sees the ID number,
and knows, okay, this
is a request from David.
- Now, the internet is completely open,
all of its connections are shared,
and information is sent in plain text.
This makes it possible for hackers
to snoop on any personal information
that you send over the internet,
but safe websites prevent this
by asking your web browser
to communicate on a secure channel
using something called
Secure Sockets Layer
and its successor
Transport Layer Security.
You can think of SSL and
TLS as a layer of security
wrapped around your communications
to protect them from
snooping or tampering.
SSL and TLS are active when
you see the little lock
that appears in your browser address bar
next to the HTTPS.
The HTTPS protocols ensure that your
HTTP requests are secure and protected.
When a website asks your browser
to engage in a secure connection,
it first provides a digital certificate,
which is like an official ID card
proving that it's the
website it claims to be.
Digital certificates are published
by certificate authorities,
which are trusted entities
that verify the identities
of websites and issue
certificates for them,
just like a government can
issue IDs or passports.
Now, if a website tries to
start a secure connection
without a properly issued
digital certificate,
your browser will warn you.
That's the basics of web browsing,
the part of the internet
we see day to day.
To summarize, HTTP and DNS manage
the sending and receiving of HTML,
media files, or anything on the web.
What makes this possible under the hood
are TCP/IP and router networks
that break down and transport information
in small packets.
Those packets themselves
are made up of binary,
sequences of ones and zeros
that are physically sent
through electric wires,
fiber optic cables, and wireless networks.
Fortunately, once you've
learned how one layer
of the internet works, you can rely on it
without remembering all the details.
We can trust that all those
layers will work together
to successfully deliver information
at scale and with reliability.